who do you think on our staff as
passengers
has the lowest ratings on Uber this
makes sense to me Ralph is not on our
staff but Ralph is a 4.53 Ralph you know
Ralph would have been my pick this was
somewhat not shocking and shocking it
was shocking and not shocking some of it
is expected exactly maybe I don't but
you might say John Hein
wow you're good the bottom three are
John Hein with a 4.67 rating because you
know this is the guy who goes to
McDonald's and starts telling people how
they could manage the McDonald's and
won't leave the line the register blocks
people from ordering yes
who's the next one
all right uh I want to say Sal no
Benji of course no why I wasn't even
thinking of business right Benji didn't
come up in my list
Benji had a 4.6 but number three really
shocked me Samantha 4.52
Samantha you claim that a lot of times
you offer other people an Uber like your
mom
and she [__] with the drivers and then
you now have a low rating I don't take
Ubers a lot and my theory is yes I send
other people home under my account my
mother I send often and I have a feeling
that she's telling them take this way
don't take this way talking loudly on
her phone maybe eating rolling up and
down the window you know like I think
maybe being late I believe you Chris
Wilding doesn't believe you I don't know
why to be fair to Sam she's not the only
one who has this excuse but like Ralph
owns it I'm sure John Hines about to own
it Benji I don't know it just seems
strange to blame it on like your
philanthropic work as an Uber provider
that your score is so low
I think maybe you're a bit of it maybe
you're a bit of a Karen when you get in
the car I believe that Sam could
possibly not take a lot of Ubers and
could possibly be putting her mother on
various other people in the car and
getting a low rate and they're all
monsters they're given a four point
they're giving a Ralph level
excuse me I'm not saying they're
Monsters the only thing I can think of
is I have brought my dog in an Uber
before you know medical emergencies
where I've had to rush my little dog to
the you know I don't know what what
upsets someone I I want to ask and well
what about the staff besides Chris that
thinks I'm a Karen in an Uber I
suggested potentially a Karen I did not
say you're a parent you're saying in
other words you don't know for sure but
there could be an issue and you're
questioning you
let's sum it up this way Sam is blaming
her low rating on her mother and her dog
surgery and Chris is saying look I think
there's a cover-up going on and that is
the controversy now John hind for you to
have I mean I see John as a very
rational human being and understands
human behavior what is your what why are
you such a low-rated uber passenger
what's going on there is it your
obnoxious mother and your dog or is it
you
well my rating is a 4.67 as was
announced I humbly accept my bronze
medal because when I'm in the Uber as
Robin surmised I uh I have certain
standards that I expect to be met as the
drivers do with me I'm a very respectful
passenger I tip very well but I consider
it to be my ride because I'm the
customer so if the driver is on the
phone playing music I don't particularly
enjoy driving like an idiot Etc I will
let them know in a very polite way that
they're doing that and as a result I
have received like Ralph 13 one star
ratings
I have also gotten
368 five-star ratings but I understand
why my rating is what it is I accept it
and hopefully so let's say I'm a driver
and I'm listening to radio loudly and
you don't like it well you'll just say
Excuse me sir I don't want the music
blasting is that what you'll do well
first I'll do some passive aggressive
stuff like maybe roll down a window or
cough or pretend I'm on the phone and
say I can't believe this guy is playing
this music that loud
he's also a road rage person so I am
sure that the way they drive
is very irritating to him look I think
they appreciate my honest feedback
we got a pretty low rating by the way it
doesn't surprise me that Benji has a bad
Uber rating and do you have any idea why
or are you just gonna tell us you don't
I've been sending Ubers for Sam's mom
also
have such a low rating according to have
tweeted out that
um as a complaint that they had the Uber
Uber should make the drivers talk to me
okay all right now I got it you do stick
in the car you know why Benji is getting
that score
he's late yeah
I do have chicken with me for every ride
almost put her in a bag Benji a bag do
you put the dog in a bag no do you put
your mom in a bag sorry
Sam's mother is on the phone and wants
to defend herself yes go ahead real
mother yes this is Kathy
hey honey what's going on what are we
talking about today now Kathy what is
your behavior behavior in the Uber why
are you the person driving down the
rating be honest
no I could be I mean it depends on the
situation you know I mean first of all
she doesn't pay for every one of my
Ubers let's just be let me just be clear
about that so exactly okay like it's
occasional but secondly these these Uber
drivers okay depending on what's going
on I'm like I want to know what's going
on like I want to ask questions I want
to know where they're from
they don't want to I love you but they
don't want to talk to you
no it was mom well you're getting in the
car and you're going like oh so when did
you get here from Bangladesh
is that
is better mood really like where's your
wife from right now now Chris do you
believe Sam now just based on this short
conversation it sounds like this no I
think they're probably both crazy and
the Uber drivers want to hang themselves
oh my God
foreign